welcome back I just want to bring you
some live pictures now obviously all
eyes on Moscow today is President Xi
Jinping of China arrives for a three-day
State visit it's the Chinese Leader's
first trip to Russia since the start of
the war in Ukraine President Putin has
said that Russia and China are both
fighting common threats our Moscow
correspondent uh Diana Magna uh joins us
now uh died this is a very very
significant visit indeed isn't it
yes a very important diplomatic moment
really um we're seeing the uh Chinese
leader come down and be met with a sort
of ceremonial honors at the airport here
in Moscow met by a deputy prime minister
but as you say it will be a substantial
visit his first since uh President Putin
invaded Ukraine
um and you know this visit was announced
on Friday just after President Putin was
indicted by the international criminal
court you would have thought that that
might give the Chinese Premier cause for
thought but apparently not and let's not
forget that he too is accused of war
crimes in Guangzhou Province against the
uyghur minority there
um they are expected to talk to trade
they are expected to talk uh their
substantial growing economic ties but
this is not a partnership of equals this
is a a a a partnership it where Russia
is very much the junior partner isolated
on the world stage looking for Russia as
a market to sell its gas and its energy
China is getting that at substantially
reduced prices and of course this is
also a moment where both leaders want to
show and especially Xi Jinping want to
show that they are a a peace broker in
terms of the Ukraine war a UK the
Ukraine crisis is the way that Xi
Jinping names this he hasn't called it a
war he hasn't condemned Russia he hasn't
accused Russia of being the aggressor in
this but he has laid out a very vague
peace plan which I think
Ukraine for one finds uh impossible to
countenance because it would just
acknowledge Russia's territorial gains
over the last year
um but I think that the Chinese
sort of advises are pretty clear that at
this stage there will be no hope to the
war because both parties want to see
whether they can make more gains before
they'll be prepared to sit down and
actually talk for peace but I think Xi
Jinping wants to project himself as a
key player in any resolution of this
conflict and of course we've had
editorials from both sides from
President Putin and Xi Jinping already
in each other's respective major
newspapers where they've talked about
the threat that they both face from
American hegemony from bullying and how
they are committed to world peace and a
multi-polar world order and that is very
much for the audience in the global
South
um but I think you know this is a really
a a boost for Vladimir Putin to have the
Chinese leader come to see him one year
into his War they've declared themselves
a partnership with no limits we'll have
to see whether that is the case I think
that um there are concerns of course
from America that Xi Jinping will be
providing And discussing at this meeting
providing Russia with weapons to fuel
its war effort there's been reporting
last week from Politico that Chinese
China was already providing uh rifles to
Russia and there are other dual use
technologies that are coming in to
support Russia's efforts that really
would crystallize
um much more of a cold war situation
with Russia and China against NATO I
don't think China wants to be seen to go
that far particularly because of the
importance for China of continuing its
economic ties with Europe and with the
rest of the world but everybody will be
watching very closely the outcome of
these meetings tomorrow we'll we'll get
more out of it than today today there
are informal talks between the Chinese
leader and Vladimir Putin tomorrow both
sides delegations will meet there will
be substantial talks there will be a
press conference so there'll be a lot of
news coming from Russia over the next
couple of days
I mentioned just now uh ji's Ambitions
as a sort of Peace broker obviously
we've seen that in the Middle East last
week uh brokering talks between the
Saudis and the Iranians um we're told
that he is going to be speaking to
president zielinski of Ukraine by
telephone at some point do we get any
sort of readout from the Chinese as to
when that's going to take place
not yet presumably after these calls uh
after these talks with Vladimir Putin
um you you would have thought that given
President Biden's unexpected uh
appearance in Kiev a couple of weeks
back it wouldn't be a bad opportunity
for the Chinese leader to do the same
thing but the expectation is that it
will just be a phone call with Vladimir
zielensky who has said in the past when
China put out its peace proposals that
he would be happy to discuss them going
forward with China but it does seem very
one-sided that you have this huge State
visit from the Chinese leader
um a sort of pat on the back for
Vladimir Putin who's called him his good
old friend uh XI jinping's been slightly
more restrained in his terminology in
the letter that he wrote about this
meeting
um and that he'll just make a telephone
call to Kiev but it's better than
nothing and I think that that is um you
know the expectations that he can
actually play a role in brokering peace
at the moment pretty limited basically
because neither side is really looking
for peace quite yet but it is possible
that he will be able If he if he
believes or wants it to uh to to weigh
in you know as this situation continues